uh next we have this from the daily wire
former and current female inmates
speaking of uh prison populations
former and current female inmates from
liberal states like california
washington are speaking out about
gender laws which allow biologically
male inmates who identify as female to
share prison cells with them
one woman recalled sharing and this gets
a little graphic by the way she said
fair warning but
i think everyone needs to know what's
going on here
so um a little graphic but one woman
recalled sharing a cell with a man
who sustained quote a full erection
another noted how female inmates
um many victims of past sexual assault
are arming themselves out of fear of
victimization from
300 pound men who quote look like
hercules
um those women spoke to abigail schreier
author of irreversible damage the
transgender craze seducing our daughters
a book which i read recently and i've
talked about on the show and i would
highly recommend that book to everyone
um
but they spoke with her and she she was
she was talking about their their plight
former inmate tyrina griffin told
schreier that quote many of the men who
are transferring there aren't even on
hormonal
medication she told the author quote
they're getting a full erection
so you're locked in this room 24 7 with
a man and there's nothing you can do
about it
if you tell the police you don't want to
live with a man or you're afraid or
whatever
you'll get a disciplinary infraction so
you're basically punished for being
scared
another former inmate amy ichikawa
explained that central california
women's facility in chauchila
does not separate inmates based on
severity of crime due to the nature of
women's facilities being significantly
less violent than men's facilities
so when biologically male inmates are
transferred in
they're mixed with inmates without
regard to the nature of their crime
ichikawa said quote we're all mixed
together the people who've murdered
their children are in the same room as
the people who've stolen boxers
from walmart and uh it's it's worth
reading this report because it goes into
to more detail than that and all of it
is absolutely horrifying now
i said just a moment ago that
prisons are a place of suffering there's
no doubt about that
and that's not a bad thing because if
you're a criminal you should suffer
all criminals should suffer just not to
the same degree i mean obviously someone
who
steals boxers from walmart isn't going
to suffer it shouldn't be made to suffer
in the same way that
a violent criminal or murderer should
but there should be
a punishment yeah that's the thing with
with
uh now now i'm kind of backtracking to
the other conversation we'll loop back
around in a second but
we have to be clear and i think we have
this muddled idea these days about what
prison even
is and why it exists in the first place
and i would say that it exists for two
reasons and they're equally as important
one reason is to segregate dangerous
people from society
that that's part of it that's really
important especially if you live in one
of these communities where these violent
criminals tend to uh
tend to also live but we can't forget
the other part of it
is punishment it is an actual punishment
and part of being punished is suffering
and that is good again for society it
helps to maintain a properly ordered
society it helps to keep society safe
there's also a deterrent element to it
but it's good for the for the criminal
to have to suffer
and to confront the severity of their
own crimes and that's how if there's any
chance of reconciliation if there's any
chance of
of personal reform of turning a new leaf
it's not going to happen
unless the people who commit these
crimes are made to suffer so
so that's that
there should be suffering in prison but
there's also
a concept of cruel and unusual
punishment
which is in our constitution and that's
a good thing
because as i said there's a limit and
there are degrees of suffering
and this is all supposed to be
calibrated based on the severity of
crime and everything
so putting women many of them not even
violent criminals
you know shoplifters
illegal drug users and so on locking
them
in cells with with these
large violent men for 24 hours a day
that is cruel and unusual punishment it
is unconstitutional
it is a it's a horrifying
form of torture and neglect
and these women are being literally
science we hear so much about
well women are being silenced in most
cases that's
not the case at all most of the women
who are out screaming that they're being
silenced well
they're screaming and we hear them so
they're not being silenced
but these women in prison they are
literally being silenced
as we heard from one of them one of them
say if they if they speak out against it
or if they object
if they say hey um this is a this is a
dude you've just put me in a
prison cell with this is a dude who
isn't even making an effort
to pretend that he's a woman if they say
that they're gonna they get
punished for it
if you care if you really cared at all
about number one women's rights
and number two um the the
unjust suffering and the unjust
punishment of
of criminals if you cared about any of
that
or all of it then you'd be speaking out
loudly about this
you'd be holding press conferences about
this
alexandria case of cortez she's not
going to say a damn word about this is
it because she doesn't know oh she knows
is she is it because she doesn't realize
that it's insane
to be putting taking women and putting
them in prison in jail cells with
with 300 pound men
does she not real no she realizes that
it's insane also
despite how it may seem most of these
democrats including alexandria cortez
look they're radical they're dishonest
um but they're most of them are not
stupid
you know it may seem like they are but
they're they're they're at least they're
not as dumb as they come across
they know what they're doing
and they know that this is wrong but
they're not going to say anything about
it because they care more about their
ideology
than the suffering of anyone including
women
and all of this is based on you know
we're putting men in women's prisons
it's based on the honor system
like you you might as well just uh
have no bars and no walls in the prison
and and base the entire thing on the
honor system
you know here's your here's your spot
where you're supposed to be in jail for
the next 27 years
we're not gonna have any guards we're
not gonna have any any walls or anything
honor system okay
i mean you're you're a murderer i'm sure
you i'm sure i'm sure we can trust your
personal
sense of honor and integrity so on the
honor system
they're letting men into women's prisons
because the men claim that they identify
as women or really
feel deep down that they're women
there's no way to confirm that
it's just they said it and so oh who
would love
this is a this is a a murderer and sex
offender
he wouldn't lie about this
and of course even if we could confirm
that they really do identify as women
that wouldn't make a damn bit of
difference because they still don't
belong in women's prisons because
they're not women
um but the point is that a lot of these
guys
they don't even really identify as women
they identify as far as just saying oh
yeah i'm a woman
in fact if if you're a violent male
criminal in a place like california
why wouldn't you at this point just come
out and say uh yeah i'm a woman too
send me the women's prison
that's what a lot of them are doing and
uh we have to respect their
self-identity
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content